c'est un futur centre de cauwer king
dédié à l'automobile cet espace de la
start-up yvelinoise value mycar
proposera six box en location lavage
mécanique ou esthétisme particuliers
professionnels auront à disposition les
outils nécessaires pour ses activités
on va équiper ce sébum d'entretien
mécanique des des mets des meilleurs
matériels professionnels que ce soit au
niveau des dépouilles
nous allons installer ou de l'ensemble
des outils du matériel soit mis à
disposition il y aura également dans ses
boxes d'entretien mécanique des écrans
géants que l'on pourra piloter de son
iphone et sur lequel on pourra diffuser
le tuto de la prestation pour laquelle
on est venu et eau pour lequel on a on a
réservé son blog
ce projet vise aussi à créer une
communauté autour de l'automobile dans
ce centre dans la zone d'activités de
gaz rend l'objectif de value my car
c'est vraiment de de mettre à
disposition ses techniques et ses
matériels des français de manière à ce
que pour ceux qui ont envie de rouler
dans un véhicule dans un état aussi
rapprochés que possible
il est apposé la possibilité de le faire
créée en mars 2020 value macquart est
d'abord une plateforme de mise en
relation entre particuliers et experts
du monde de l'automobile réparation
entretien du véhicule value mycar
accompagne aussi les prestataires sur
les formalités administratives
un projet autour d'une vingtaine de
personnes et plusieurs millions d'euros
investis grâce à cette barre de
recherche et un algorithme que nous
avons spécifiquement développées
l'automobiliste est mis en relation avec
des prestataires proche de chez lui qui
ont le savoir faire pour répondre à son
besoin
la livraison de ce centre automobile est
prévue en novembre prochain
les premiers clients seront accueillis
en début d'année 2021